the wildfire risk is so high because the
landscape is tinder dry almost every
part of the uk had less rain than normal
over the last month with a significant
rainfall deficit just the west and north
of scotland have been wet if you're in
the south or east of england you won't
be surprised to hear it's been extremely
dry in fact july and the start of august
have been the driest on record
scientists call it a meteorological
drought and it goes back many months
this is the map for the last year and
again it's the south and east of england
and also part of the northeast that have
had much less rain than usual
that's having a big impact on rivers
these are the monitoring sites for water
flow in rivers across england
where the dots are red it's below normal
for the time of year and if they're dark
red the river flow is exceptionally low
from cornwall to northumberland the
drought is beginning to bite
take the river thames at windsor the
beige band shows the normal water flow
for the time of year higher in the
winter lower in the summer the black
line is this year's data in march the
flow was healthy but it's been dropping
fast ever since now well into the red
zone and still falling
if water's pressure's right now leaks as
big as this really don't help a burst
water main flooded roads in holloway
north london
droughts happen regularly and to make
the uk more resilient scientists say
water companies need to fix pipes store
more winter rain and encourage consumers
to use less
we are living in quite difficult times
climate related times that the climate
is changing and we are going into
periods of
longer drive periods which will
definitely
impact water supply then
for that
uh communicating that and getting
everyone on board i think would help
the forecast is for another heat wave
this week with temperatures climbing
well into the 30s in some areas and with
no rain on the horizon the demand for
water will rise still further